these same men reported that they've
been in situations where they could have
had sex but they didn't feel confident
in themselves to say you know what I can
do this right but and you know whether
insecurity actually comes from other men
men go out talking about their game okay
oh I've got this you know I can pull any
girl it makes other men actually feel
insecure in themselves when actually in
reality women will have sex with any man
as long as you fulfill her needs it
doesn't have to be sexual it can be
emotional need it can speak for yourself
any man okay
but in this time if this guy made you
fall like a queen email I'm sorry I'm a
tall girl I'm a tall girl I'm six foot
right it doesn't matter how good a 5'5
guy makes me feel right